i'm gonna start with uh congratulations
on the movie you guys did such a great
job with it
thanks thanks that means a lot it was uh
a pretty ambitious undertaking and it
took a lot out of us and of course we we
had the pandemic to deal with as well
that really kind of was a bit of a
monkey wrench in the middle of the
process
um but to to hear how people are
responding to it um has been incredibly
emotional and really gratifying so thank
you jumping back to the beginning of
this thing um how did this project end
up at netflix was it one of these things
you've been thinking about for a while
like talk a little bit about the genesis
yeah
this was a very long road because it
really does you probably get a sense
from watching the movie that it goes all
the way back to my childhood loves you
know um
certainly raiders lost ark you know
those kind of like rollicking adventure
stories king kong was a big thing for me
i love the hairy house and stop-motion
films the sinbad clash of the titans
those kind of things were really
important to me as a kid and and i think
they really motivate motivated me to
want to make stories even things like
road warrior was a big thing for me i
just love big action spectacle and
action adventure to me is is a genre
that i love
um so it's always been in me right
and uh and and
and i've been lucky to
to be i was at disney for almost 25
years and i've worked on movies that i'm
really proud of
but there was a genre that i really
wanted to take on
um that was just a little bit outside of
what disney would do
um and and this this this this itch
that i wanted to scratch really became
um
coincided with
a moment in my life where i was kind of
taking stock because i had been at
disney for almost 25 years and that was
half my life at that point
and and i and i there was there was a
moment there were fights if i stayed any
longer i was going to become a disney
lifer right
and and that is not a bad thing but i
wanted it to be a choice if that was
going to be the case i wanted to be a
choice and so i'd moved from canada to
work at
disney at a young age and i just put my
head down and did the work and
and i wanted to kind of educate myself
as to what else was out there and and so
i met with lots of different studios and
and and
as i did i just found myself i found
this compulsion as an artist i wanted to
make myself uncomfortable
um i was very comfortable and very
treated very well at disney um but i
wanted i wanted change for its own sake
i wanted as an artist to challenge
myself
uh and throw myself into it into a into
a very different situation and netflix
in
in some ways is the antithesis right
like the disney's this eternal company
that's been around forever and and you
come along and you're part caretaker of
the legacy and then you hand it off and
and netflix was this brand new thing
that is still coming into being right um
and and it was there was something about
it that's that made me feel like this
this feels like a big big change and
that's exactly what i was looking for
um and they were open to something
totally that was a little bit outside of
what i probably could have done at
disney and
and and so i talked about this this big
rollicking adventure story and and they
were excited by it and
and i was like you know this is pretty
ambitious
this is going to be a big one and they
knew they understood and they have been
incredibly supportive throughout and and
here we are we made a movie uh animating
any movie is a difficult challenge but
animating something with water is like
another level maybe people don't really
realize that can you sort of explain to
people
when you tell an animator that there's
going to be a lot of water in a movie
the look that hits their face
i don't recommend it it's
because it's it's the animators but it's
also the camera operators and it's the
the the the the
it
technologically it's it's a challenge
you know um i if i go back to uh big
hero 6 we were really limited as far as
how much water interaction we could have
even moana which obviously takes place
out in the water there was a finite
number of times we could have the
characters
go in and out of the water on on screen
you know like the there there's a cost
to those things they're very complicated
um
and then now i obviously didn't learn my
lesson because now though you know so
much of the movie takes place out at sea
there's a lot of characters they're all
on these boats and ships and things
um and there isn't an added challenge
animation because not only are you
trying to
um uh you know
express a performance as an actor as an
animator you're an actor
and and that's primarily your job but
there's also the physics and the
physicality and if the thing you're on
is moving
on on a surface that is moving that that
creates its own its own added challenges
and so yeah that that accounts for
probably that glazed look they um they
they did help in the technology front
where if there was
if there was a minor movement um of a
ship that there was this
there was a
thing that they had implemented that
that had naturally the characters
compensating with their body weight to
that but you know you've seen the movie
so you know a lot of times it wasn't
gentle
and so they had to account for some
really challenging
uh
physics and physicality uh because of
the fact it was on water yeah even the
opening of the movie though like right
the opening sequence you have someone in
the water you have a fire you have the
the boat the ship and i'm the opening
sequence i'm like oh
i almost cursed i'm like oh this is this
is this looks amazing like oh my god
they really right from the opening scene
i was like oh this is a thing yeah yeah
i i definitely i i went pretty
big as far as my as far as my ambition
goes i wanted to go all the way you know
what i mean and
i love
you know who i love is george miller you
know i when you look at road warrior and
you look at fury road you see someone
who is
is insanely ambitious right
um and and and and asks a lot
of of of of the crew you know that he
wants to go really really far
and and and the road war was a huge
moment for me seeing that movie
um and and has stayed with me and so i
really wanted to create moments of great
spectacle
um in in this movie and and it's that
that's easy for me to say you know teach
me to say i wanted to be big and
spectacular
um it's it's the hundreds of artists
that have to execute it right and and so
i can in a way myself look at and be and
feel like
this looks impossible
you actually did you actually did what i
wanted you to do how's that even
possible um and uh how is it how are you
capable of that um and i i think it's
just there's there's a character to this
small community of of people who work in
animation where they really love a
challenge you know that if they hear
something's hard if they hear
something's going to be if there's if
there's that we're trying something new
they don't shy away from that they want
it you know and uh and and and as the
director of animation you benefit from
that that strength of character uh uh
and that curiosity that that people who
work in animation have so the movie is
about two hours give or take um and
every minute of animation costs real
money was there ever any pressure to
bring it down closer to 90 minutes or
you know an hour and 40 minutes
no i
i i was very supportive through the
whole process and i think some of it is
i was very open from the beginning about
what my ambitions were and and
and the the script was no secret and
they knew what they were getting into
right and but they they responded to the
story and they wanted to serve the story
and
and and the people that that i work for
they're they're passionate about movies
too and and so when they saw what what
this needed to be they were incredibly
supportive and i really appreciated not
having to have those those battles um i
think as as uh
as a director you're always a little bit
at war with yourself because you want to
be responsible you don't want to
waste people's time and waste money
unnecessarily
but you want the movie to be great and
you don't want anything to get in the
way of making the movie better and so
you're always trying to push for more
and more and more
and uh and and and maybe like oh can i
have one more crack at that at that beat
you know can i just i think i can make
that better
and and
and i and i feel like i was i was very
lucky with the with with with the crew
that that made the movie but also with
the executives that i answered to
uh everyone was really really rallied
around this movie
and i think saw the potential that it
had what did you learn from any like
early friends and family screenings or
any i mean with covid i mean i don't
know if you did any test screenings but
what did you learn from those early
screenings that impacted finished film
well the the that that's a good question
because the
the i i i'm gonna there's a two-parter
um the uh
we we only had one screening typical
animation screening where we screen for
our crew in a theater because after that
covet struck right um so we had we had
one screening our first screening
and even even in the anticipation of it
there was something about it that felt
off to me because the maisy brumble
character was not in the first iteration
of the movie um there was it was a very
different story where captain crow had
stolen a baby from from his mother
and and uh and and i i could i could
feel as we were building towards that
screening that it wasn't working the
story wasn't working fundamentally
which is nothing new for me
uh every movie i've ever worked on or
been around has evolved
massively in the course of the
development of the story and usually
that's a good thing usually it means
that people are searching for the better
version it's if the movie gets sort of
locked and plateaus early on that's when
i start to get more nervous because it
means that people aren't really
challenging their assumptions right
so there was a huge change plot-wise
story-wise
based on our very first screening
um then we ins we we brought in the
maisy character things started to click
the story really started to feel good to
me
um and after that we unfortunately
weren't able to have in-person
screenings but we would send links out
to people and they would watch it and we
only had one sort of general audience
preview screening
and we were feeling good about the story
and really primarily it was to see how
younger
audience members would react to this
movie because of a bit more of a sense
of peril and danger or maybe a little
scarier than other movies that i've
worked on
um and just to sort of see like how is
this going to play with that with that
segment of the audience
and it was so cool because we had
and i never thought of this movie i
never think of any movies i've worked on
as being for kids right um if you work
at disney you certainly have to be
cognizant of the fact that it has to be
you know acceptable for kids to watch it
um
the main audience is me and my story
team right
that's who we're trying to make a great
movie for um and and this one certainly
as we were making the sea beast we never
thought this is a movie for kids we
thought this is a movie for audiences
who love adventure stories
um
but still there's this curiosity hollow
play with younger kids and and so they
had this they had um
uh a moderated uh uh meeting a zoom
meeting afterwards where they had a
bunch of kids who were probably between
like eight and ten who'd seen the film
um and they asked them was there
anything that was scary
um and they cited the character that
they referred to as the witch they kept
saying oh the witch was scared which was
scary
and uh and
there and the moderator is like oh so
you would like less of the witch and
they all said no we want more of the
wish
and that was a
very telling moment you know because
kids do like to be a little scared at
times you know they want to find that
threshold that feels right for them
and uh and it definitely put people's
minds at ease and far as far as how um
approachable this movie would be for
younger audiences making every animated
movie i've heard you you know you invent
new tools new software to help you make
the movie which can help you in future
endeavors um what were some of the tools
you guys invented on this that you know
will help you on a future project
well i i will start by saying i am not
an expert when it comes to technology
and i can barely work my phone but i
know i know from conversations with with
with the crew
that one of the things they knew was
that ropes were going to be a challenge
ropes are notoriously challenging in
animation
um because there's no give to them you
know there's no there's no flexibility
to them
and and i know firsthand from moana that
the ropes on the juana's boat almost
sank the whole movie
um and now here and there's only like 10
ropes on her boat now you go to these
tall ships there's literally hundreds of
ropes
the good thing is the the folks at sony
image works they were they were they
knew that was going to be a challenge
and so they attacked it early on and it
was never really that much of a thing
but i know the thing that kind of
blindsided us as far as like
the the a technical challenge was the
sails themselves and how they filled
with wind um because we wanted to get
that right we always knew the wind
direction in all of our scenes and we
always wanted the maneuvering of the
ship to be accurate and the ships had to
behave and the story the sails had to
behave accordingly
and you know that was one of those ones
where they they hadn't done that kind of
thing before
and so that was a new challenge and and
took a long time before we were able to
look at a ship that where the sails
filled with with wind where it looked
right
and that was like the the touchiest
thing for us where we just couldn't get
these sails to work
um and it was relatively late in the
game where we finally did and then it
was this big hallelujah moment like we
got there's a wide shot of the ship
that we that you see fairly early on in
in the first in the opening battle scene
uh where the ship was you could see the
complete ship wide shot sales filled
with wind and it was this it was a party
it was a celebration hallelujah we can
do it
and of course you know in the course of
the story it just kind of breezes on by
and the audience may not take note of it
but it was meaningful for us and so now
for the the folks that at sony they
would be able to
fill sales of wind all day long
um on that note i need to stop i'm just
gonna say congrats on making a great
film uh and i really hope it's a huge
hit for uh for you guys thank you thank
you so much thank you for your support
it means a lot